All right.
I do still feel that a great collection
is not based necessarily on value.
Um,
if I was putting together an American
industrial design collection,
which I've kind of dabbled with over the
years,
it's absolutely possible to put in
artifacts,
whether it's a meat slicer by Egmont
errands or an outboard motor or a
cocktail shaker that you can acquire on
Ebay.
You can acquire at the low budget kind
of swap meet shows like the triple pier
show here in Manhattan where you can,
you can only spend a few hundred dollars
for some of these things,
but it's how selective you are.
I think there's two forms of
collections.
There's collections that take a
curatorial eye and really just focused
on a certain theme and develop that
theme and every piece juxtaposes with
each other.
And then there's the great obsessives,
the the people that have to have
everything by that designer and maybe
those collectors,
the best of that group are the ones who
as years go by,
are not afraid to refine that collection
and sell off certain stuff that isn't
quite holding the test of time.
So I identify with both the obsessive
compulsive collecting community and the
minimalist.
I want to Imitate v try and create a
perfect chair collection.